[Music]
sorry I got so mad this means we've got
pesky please intruder attack and
drowning tortoises take away its kissing
is also like drowning tortoises dress
won't be swimming yeah they're on land
okay so for our first story it has been
reported that they found please that
have tested positive for the sling what
are you talking about
the plague that [ __ ] ravaged through
Europe in the Middle East and all the
way to Asia [ __ ] black death I
can't believe the government is going to
do a [ __ ] crazy extent to inject
fleas now with the plague that might be
happening this happened back in the 30s
when everyone died from a plague
no this is like before the 30s oh my god
are the dark ages 30 31 like the Great
Depression bro 1300 not what I meant
I said 13 so what happened that means
these fleas been surviving off of some
fleabag ass dogs that's been carrying
these [ __ ] that's what carry
those [ __ ] is on the flees from
the rat from rat yep all throughout
Europe you know that homeland of NGO
come on a nice nice book business and as
I said every you know that they're
saying that they believe that the plague
originated in China the Chinese people
dirty of course I don't know everything
happened in check how come they didn't
dive in there just a minute
oh if the Chinese smallpox I don't know
where it came but the rumor is it came
from rat the fleas that stayed on rats
and it traveled from the Silk Route all
the way into Europe but it went wrap it
in Europe because the medieval cities
were very dirty so dirty they would take
a ship and then they would get the [ __ ]
ball and and just throw it out the
window or out the window
people walking have umbrellas they're
gonna get [ __ ] water honor
get rain in London Rose said to
minorities with dirty [ __ ] white
people old white people not the new
white people don't get a sense medieval
white people visual white people nothing
new new white people white Daniel was it
work was crazy because apparently it
killed more than 20 million people in
Europe yeah all of that are estimated
between 75 to 200 million Wow
on the brighter note though thanks to
that we have the Renaissance when
abundance of food after all the people
died yeah you don't to share as much
mm-hmm so eventually the disease did die
out because everyone would die and then
the rodents would be dying as well and
then there was a another outbreak Asia
and then it just circled back again and
it was way more people I kept dying
people kept coughing from from why
people coughing on Asians Asians Kaufman
on why people it keeps coming back and
forth like a ping-pong game I know it's
like a ping-pong game between Europe and
[Laughter]
it will die all over the place yeah you
know that song ring around the Rosie yes
apparently it was based off of the clean
dude all of those [ __ ] kid lullabies
lullabies their morbid [ __ ] you mean
nursery rhymes the nursery has all of us
lullabies when you go to sleep oh that's
the reason oh yeah no you just you just
dance around I find [ __ ] it
whatever yeah yeah okay everybody
Rockabye Baby
yeah that's a lullaby wind blows the
cradle hold is raw like blend you're
talking about to the bass master falling
down that's [ __ ] up that was through
the whole war thing yes but it's still
with like kids singing it definitely put
that in scary movies because it's morbid
that's dope [ __ ] chopping heads
chocolate - pets [ __ ] chocolate
you can anger your Jamali in children
course I'll be dull yeah
I'll kill your mom to kill your mother
pedophiles character whip just a whisper
so room yes please a very sound in
Arizona
what you got clothes what is happening
there I don't know and how did they find
out I'm not sure I just saying that they
were testing sleeves in different areas
and that just leaves come out positive
we're just randomly checking for the
Black Plague who does that
what is our money going why the [ __ ] are
we testing food I didn't know you were
testing fleas on the random yeah they're
collecting them like near Lake areas can
they tell us where these fleas are like
coming from Arizona I mean like what
specific is it around Phoenix reducing
our fleas coming from the grass and in
Arizona there's no grass it was a bunch
it's a [ __ ] desert
yeah another origin of what if somebody
got infected and then they're like oh
[ __ ] we got to hide this so that no way
for example out the third body and we'll
just say we're going to test random
fleas or there's some other needed
happening that's greater like the
[ __ ] government's injecting them then
it has something greater that's
happening in the news right now that
they're trying to deflect attention to
they're like oh plague filled you know
flea they're coming to get you but well
there's like racism [ __ ] shady [ __ ]
happening or diarrhea all this stuff
going on you're trying to distract it
from that reason yeah the Black Death is
pretty crazy though I don't get to go to
the catacombs for everybody else did I
know I wanted to go didn't go either did
you go no I didn't go hell no I'm not
going to bring my pregnant wife to that
please
Pano's gonna carry a demon - exactly
thanks laughs why not wait I'm on his
side I'm not no no I might read that
really that allows you it could happen
it happens in the movies right all the
silent movies are really any movies ever
like yes I don't talk with those here
saving all those bodies in the catacombs
a lot of them are from the black - yeah
didn't we get that in Europe - remember
that part that's like everyone goes and
they visit now but then back when the
plot the plague was around it was like
filled up with a bunch of bodies because
they don't know what to do with it your
eyes what I remember that part
ah that when you guys conceived it was
in Paris no that was in London hmm
I don't know what to do if we had the
plague in the United States it's not
cure my [ __ ] nope uh they're saying that
if you do pitchers died no if you if you
catch it and like the fact that you have
symptoms and it could be treated with
antibiotics you know what's [ __ ] up
really oh yeah I did have that about
with all of these diseases though if you
go to WebMD they are all all the same
symptoms like screams oh yeah lecture
like it even ages flu-like symptoms and
you know what like my stubborn ass
Asians just don't like the hospital like
we don't go to the doctor we think
nothing ever wrong I could have a
[ __ ] 200 degree the [ __ ]
temperature and I'm like bleeding out of
my [ __ ] and I'm like it's just a cold
I'm going to sleep it but this is like
you need to take tylenol and I'm like
[ __ ] that I'm going to destroy my liver
I'm going to sleep stay here internally
rod now I just draw my listen now
apparently there's three forms of the
plague there's a bubonic plague the
sepsis emic plague and the pneumonic
plague
why does bubonic sound like a dope
strain of weed because it is because it
is oh it is bubonic chronic purple body
Snoop Dogg saying about it that's why
okay
yeah each time a has different symptoms
and stuff in the course they're barely
symptoms appear 2 to 6 days after we
close do it so once your eyeball set
within you should go to the cops
pretty much I don't like to play yes
they're just they're just warning
Arizona citizens be careful to lock up
your pet rock them on what the [ __ ] I
like would make sure that their lease I
throw them in the freezer
don't let them roll roam around like or
just use sweet Romans oven beastly then
no freedom in the oven know you and if
you like skin while animals to wear
gloves and all these other don't wear
the skin yeah pretty much
all right Brian next story there was
this family in Virginia that they walked
into their home and discovered that
there was an intruder in their homes
your [ __ ]
the reason why they found that out is
because they found a blood trail
all over the house and it turned out
that their that their dogs a German
Shepherd
whoo save the day and a taxi intruder
and there's just a whole bunch of blood
everywhere Lucas Wow but then true
didn't take anything I thought it was
like a lady burglar I was on her period
and she ran away that's where your mind
went I just oxidized what I thought was
on the dog had a period and was just
walking her that dog - yeah dogs have no
dogs have two very laws not the boy
you're spotting yeah
four or five I don't know maybe I just
thought the intruder got cut intruding
oh maybe no they're saying that there
once they walked in through the front
door they didn't notice anything was
wrong until they started looking around
a solid body parts everywhere it's not
like like - blood everywhere I love it
when dogs bite people eat you eat you
the intruder didn't do like something
stupid where they try to sue those well
they still don't know who the intruder
was because it by the time I got home
like there was no one there and they
can't add stuff to the arm
we know it is Virginia it's not
California okay let me show you guys the
video of the homeowner taking like a
like a snapchat of all the blood
evidence what the hell whoa brah oh [ __ ]
is that a napkin that all you can have
WoW is that a napkin house you deserved
it y'all deserve this [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] with me and my dog bro you don't
come in here
they don't leave nothing dude that's a
that guy's a [ __ ] genius who he
probably murdered someone and set that
whole [ __ ] up mmm maybe for the mighty
[ __ ] genius
that dog looks like a big raccoon a guy
looks like a Akita bless you hit it look
cute he looks like a different kind of
German Shepherd way to play baseball
save the day dan that's not imagine you
guys walked in one day and you just see
meat meat loaf legs almost all the meat
ball every time you guys named him I
always want to call him me both
jaimé load he's a loaf not a bomb now
it's crazy or not crazy but what's
interesting is once these guys start
dying out I want to my dream dog at this
point my dream and my dreams always
change is a poodle the full-grown poodle
so I might get fastest on if you get one
you have to get afro comb and puff them
up so it looks like a big why are you
always living through my life so if you
get one though
you gotta it's got to be a big cotton
ball when God when I want we were
planning our wedding
he was giving his consent about the
wedding now naming our kid so it has
hoary sea yes I know I got you have
faith you know what TIFF kind of took my
suggestion for the wedding thing because
she came out looking like a Chinese girl
oh yeah and then I was like I want a
Mexican meets Asian wedding and you met
halfway because you did the France
French thing at which is a western style
I need two Chinese things all times it's
a Mexican thing to the money dance
that's my oh you have a money bad yeah
the stripper thing yeah haha yeah we
were all painting dollars on first it
depends where you pin them that makes it
cheaper yeah oh really
oh okay glassware we shoot all pens all
where you put it alright for a lot of
story there was a pet owner that saved
is drowning tortoise by giving it
mouth-to-mouth for an hour and it
knuckle was just horny he was just
trying to make out with his turtle
turtle ported hahahaha course it Gordon
was going on its afford to go as a for a
whole hour
John was giving mouth-to-mouth how old
is this tortoise because they kind of a
long time so if it was like 100 years
old I get it
forty-five years old I get it wait this
this guy get like for a whole hour
straight kept giving mouth-to-mouth
yeah I'm massaging like the stomach in
the leg well I would have gave up after
two minutes I just told you don't give
up huh yeah never give up how was he so
sure that after an hour the tortoise was
going to come back to life
the thing was when you started giving
mouth-to-mouth apparently like a little
like teaspoon size of water came up in
the lung so what happened was he has a
tortoise Fred uh so Fred I was in the
backyard he has a pond there and so
she's never really gone into the pond so
then this one particular day he was
looking for her and he found her in the
pond if she's trying to kill herself and
he brought her back and she's like ah on
as when he found her and uh nothing he
was he was actually really like this
draught that he called his daughter and
like she was just like huh no no it's
cute but then eventually he was like you
know what I'm going to try to say
realized so then that's when he started
giving mouth-to-mouth to Mike massaging
her and they're like a peaceful inside'
the water came up from her lungs and
then you just kept going and making sure
like he like she was responding somehow
and Mikey said I won't point Mikey rot
like she brought her her head in to her
shell and so he was like okay I think I
saved her so you just persistent and he
saved his pet turtle that's awesome her
tortoise daddy was born here's John
beretta doing he probably had her he was
a little kid
yeah probably this my super attached to
that guy that Torres is going to outlive
him yeah
let's see if she returns the neighbor
and I pictured it to be away long bigger
right I have this picture in something
like that yeah big is really big but
that's pretty amazing the one that me
and my friend save was like this big wow
that's use the same story of out a
friend named Derek and yet two tortoises
that is grabbed heads passed down to him
so I think they're both like 70 or 80
years old and then they just live in
like this little fenced off very of the
backyard and they would just feed them
lettuce and like roses because they
really like to eat the petals and then
one day we're just fact we're just in
the backyard hanging out and I'm like
hey where's your tortoise is that the
other one minute should be back there we
started looking then we see one and I
look at the pool and the other tortoise
is just at the bottom of the plug
I wasn't moving in a Derek saw so he
jumped in and he grabbed it but I was
heavy so he would try to like give it to
me and I grabbed then we put him out and
then same thing this one is a brick and
like a little bit of water came out they
would start breathing they see little
bubbles coming on the nose oh poor buddy
oh yeah give CPR you just let it sit
there and just yakked out the wall I
know we don't have to give see probably
my friend crying because it's like when
you have a pet we have dogs better like
ten years right and then this one's 40
years but then if you have a pet that
was passed down from their grandparents
to your parent oh you it's like a living
legend has a completely different
attachment and then like whatever
attachment you have with your dog times
that by like a hundred you know and I
just saw my ball and I'm I thought
that's crazy I had to go home at all do
they live like in the backyard how do
you keep - in the backyard that's a
family heirloom for me how do you even
get out of this territory and going to
the pool I think they just bit through
that chicken wire oh and that Moses dumb
just went to the portage by this tall
straight down maybe trying to drink some
water and in me they would and it
slipped inside editor Spears you
probably holding his breath the whole
time too because you know I like turtles
and reptiles they probably just move
really slow yeah so like they're like a
whale or you could just so they didn't
hold their breath for like ten minutes
that's all pride as soon as you hit the
water and when down is not like [ __ ]
[ __ ] is like really good son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna die [ __ ]
that's exactly what he was saying Zaza
he thinks she might have been in that
cycle by an hour Wow she was driving he
was even using a hairdryer like
massaging her like making sure like
moving her legs and so she opened Rises
or a gas main prayer
I wonder how long's a tourist can like
hold their breath is's because I want to
learn their technology because like they
could live long they could outlive like
three generations you eat lettuce but I
don't think that they're at like the
regular food like in a desert they don't
eat lettuce in a desert right like the
Piney bugs do they you're so slow how
can they catch a perfect blunder Futaba
eat a cactus oh yeah because my friends
turtle loved cactus we how do you think
though they're think like I thought it
would do you uh do you like to eat stuff
has a lot of water I try to eat like the
rose petals and then Oh mommy my
succulents I'm kicking them out so
apparently a desert tortoise diet is
mainly of safe grasses and weeds leafy
greens with small amounts amounts of
hard vegetables and moist fruits all
fruits do but I thought kind of funny
because when John was describing they
look masters how she sees her for
breeding she was just like she's eaten a
quarter of a tomato and two lettuce
leaves so I don't think she's got brain
damage she's just walking around and
looking at things like normal the only
difference is now she's looking at that
barrier around the pond that I put up
yesterday so I just thought was kind of
funny it's like full Woods's what would
be abnormal her she's just walking
around looking at students eleven is
lower
yeah I wonder if they forget like if
they would go back to the pond if they
didn't enter it off yeah I know some
really good memories I have two turtles
on my dad's house and there's a little
snapper one yeah and every time I go
towards the tank they just start jumping
up and they're like climbing because
they'd be they want food and they want
food but they remember they know every
little instinct oh I thought because
they're happy to see me play this part
food
I think turtles are wise because they're
old yep
they know the world hey you guys want to
stock any of us we'll go ahead down to
the description box below and you can
follow us on Instagram and all kinds of
stuff for more videos
[Music]
[Music]